mais non je vous assure y a pas besoin
d'être un grand écrivain pour être un
poète vous mêmes données lorsque vous
êtes heureux de voir par exemple la
beauté d'une fleur dans les pétales
s'ouvre sous les rayons du soleil ou
lorsque vous vous réjouissez du parfum
du foin fraîchement coupés et bien vous
êtes des poètes être un poète
c'est peut-être tout simplement savoir
apprécier les choses de la vie qui nous
entourent qu'elle soit gay qu'elle soit
triste
moi je lui dis donc tu es en retard
et oui je voulais terminer les rideaux
de machin vous êtes en train de faire un
jeu non nous étions en train de parler
de poésie et toi qui connais beaucoup de
poèmes et qu'il ait dit si bien faire
quelques pas nous en diront si pourquoi
pas qu'est ce que je vais vous dire un
poème de jacques prévert
c'est une très bonne idée je vais vous
dire un poème de jacques prévert qui est
complètement fou avec des mots sans
queue ni tête
ça s'appelle à tue-tête et à cloche pied
animant ce brin d'herbe est toute petite
forêt à ciel tout à fait verts et des
nuages
pour nous c'est une église dans une
malle la malle dans un grenier le
grenier dans la cave sur la tour d'un
château une photo un cheval à cheval sur
un jet d'eau le jet d'eau dans un sac à
côté d'une rose la rose d'un fraisiers
planté dans une armoire ouverte sur un
show couché dans l'épi d'un miroir sous
les halles d'un tonneau le tonneau de
vin verres dans un verre à bordeaux
bordeaux sur une falaise pour évincer
corpo
dans le tiroir d'une chaise et de
chaises en papier en pot papier de
pierre soigneusement taillée par un
tailleur de verre dans un petit gravier
tout au fond d'une main sous les plumes
d'un mouton nageant dans un lavoir à la
lueur d'un lampion éclairant une ville
il mine de crayon derrière une colline
gardé par un des groupes d'ados assis
sur la tête d'un jambon est un jambon de
fayots ces puits de porcelaine qui fait
le tour de france à pied sur une baleine
au milieu de la lune dans un quartier
perdu perdu dans une carafe une carafe
d'eau rougis dont rouge gala flamme à la
flamme d'une bougie sous la queue d'une
horloge tendu de velours rouge dans la
cour d'une école au milieu du désert où
de grands de girafes et des enfants
trouvés chante chante sans cesse à
tue-tête à cloche-pied histoire de
s'amuser
limoux sans queue ni tête qui danse dans
leur texte sans jamais s'arrêter et on
recommence à d'immenses un brin amer une
toute petite forage boselli c'est un
très joli poème est vraiment tu l'a très
bien dit voilà casimir c'est dommage
qu'il arrive si tard je suis sûr que ce
problème il y aurait plus sa luge puis
françois bonjour kazim est assez dommage
casimir que la russie tard tu as manqué
quelque chose de vraiment formidable loi
à bon vous avez mangé un gâteau à la
crème shopping mais non je leur ai bien
fun de jacques prévert et alors je pense
qu'il ya de formidable
le poème mais c'est impossible pourquoi
impossible parce que la poésie ce n'est
jamais bien tu n'aimes pas la poésie
ben non alors c'est toujours ennuyeux
tu ne sors jamais l'âme d'un poète
toikeuse et mais moi non
heureusement je serais trop malheureux
qu'est ce qui te rend heureux elle un
mois et bien par exemple
par exemple quand je vois quand la un
canard fait solide et l'eau de la mare
je suis heureux quand je vois mes amis
lapin jouer dans la rosée du matin
je suis heureux où caen ou bien quand je
vois une tourterelle traversé l'île
attire audel
je suis heureux ou bien corps vers le
soir plus rien ne bouge
quand le soleil s'habille de rouge je
suis heureux voilà tout ce qui me rend
heureux mais c'est très beau casimir
mais sa véritable poète homme ne vous
moquez pas moi vous me mettez à en voir
c'est pas vrai la poésie qui passe assez
des mots ennuyeux auquel on ne comprend
rien mais pas du tout casimir c'est
parce que simplement tu as dû lire des
mots tendres
le très mauvais poèmes ou des poèmes
trop compliqué pour toi
kazimierz que de vienne nous dire c'est
que la véritable poésie
comment ils ont actuellement besoin de
la musique des mots que de nous l'a dit
au vert je parle envers moi parfaitement
hormis mais ce n'est pas aussi le sar et
bien écoute nous allons vérifier
tu va redire ce qui te rend heureux ça
me ferait très plaisir de l'entendre une
deuxième fois une très bonne idée
juillet et nous nous allons essayer de
découvrir quels sont les rimes
il y a dans le poème de casimir vous
êtes d'accord et mais un v6 casimir
retient canton canard fait sourit des
longs de la mare qui a trouvé les rimes
canaries
très bien kathleen canard et marc
ensuite quand je vois mes amis lapin
jouer dans la rosée du matin la fin
nature ou la taille matin dans cette
attente je vois une tourterelle traversé
l'île attire onel alors tourterelles
tyrolienne tourterelles et l on sait que
ému quand vers le soir plus rien ne
bouge que le soleil s'habille de rouge
rose c'est ça
redites le camp butoir rouge et bouge
ils ont quasi mais c'est vraiment un
très très beau poème en vers et en plus
avec des rimes
tu sais on pourrait l'appeler c'est tim
horan heureux mais il y a quelque chose
qui va me rendre encore beaucoup plus
heureux qu'est-ce que ça eh bien c'est
la quête que va faire monsieur du sne
arbre quand il va apprendre que je suis
un grand poète
[Musique]
à